welcome back to curious archive this
video is a new chapter in my long
running series exploring the incredible
speculative Evolution Saga of Sarina the
world of birds Cyrano was created by The
Talented artist and World Builder Dylan
beta and many extraordinary developments
have occurred since we last explored
this distant Moon the triumphs and
tragedies the joys in the Sorrows of
this era are perhaps greater than any
that have come before so for this entry
into the archive will Chronicle the rise
and fall of fascinating species and
discover astonishing Revelations as the
world of Serena creeps ever closer to
its end
270 million years since the story began
we have now entered the late ocean age
an era where the encroachment of ice is
at its worst yet with a shallow
vegetated equatorial ocean now the last
Haven for most species on Serena when we
left off the gravediggers and
daydreamers had joined forces and
established a unified Society with the
battle against the warmongers becoming a
faint memory these two species will
create a culture that will persist on a
time scale greater than any that have
come before over the coming era
gravediggers and daydreamers will
transform the equatorial ocean into a
paradise with deep knowledge of the
principles of ecology they become
ecosystem Engineers carefully
influencing the evolution of other
species to ensure the environment
remains stable and a third intelligent
species has joined their Alliance One
descended from the earlier luddies a
playful herbivore species who have been
growing more and more intelligent and
after millions of years of co-evolution
the luddies have now become the wise
greens Keepers together these three
remarkable species collectively called
the sea stewards will influence the path
of all creatures that swim in this
shallow ocean
one of the most extreme examples of a
species whose Evolution has been shaped
by the Sea Steward's influence is the
floating bloat over 140 feet or 42
meters in length this herbivore is the
largest creature to evolve on Serena
eclipsing the length and weight of blue
whales on Earth the bloat is now so
large that it is too buoyant to fully
submerge itself instead floating along
like a boat with its elongated neck
dipping below the sea to feed on
thousands of pounds of vegetation per
day a semi-domesticated animal the
floating bloat serves as a source of
food and raw material for the sea
stewards yet lives a life of relative
Bliss
another species much changed by the Sea
Steward's presence are the awk vultures
a type of serif the awk vultures are one
of the last descendants of the
archangels that once ruled Serena's
Skies like Earth vultures awk vultures
have converged upon a scavenger Niche
feeding off the scrap piles of the sea
stewards this Behavior has caused the
awk vultures to become unusually
intelligent able to manipulate
gravediggers into offering them scraps
by performing simple tricks their
lineage to keep an eye on
within this engineered ecosystem many
species remain wild one of the more
fascinating Keystone lineages of this
era are the sea lumps an offshoot of the
land truncos we've seen in past eras sea
lumps managed to escape the ice guard
Mainland to the Lush underwater Eden
just beyond the shore now A specialized
Marine subspecies the sea lumps have
become a keystone lineage in the shallow
oceans
one species seems more changed than any
other the sea shagos once Mighty
Predators feared by all Now function as
a garbage disposal service fed by the
Sea Steward's regular supply of waste
these terrifying ant colonies have
learned not to attack the providers of
their consistent meals but the sea
shagos have not been tamed by this
partnership they have only been made
smarter the colonies know that for now
the path of least resistance is waiting
passively for offerings of garbage but
if this uneasy contract is ever
terminated the sea shagos will not
hesitate to do whatever they need to
survive
over the next several million years see
Steward Society remains remarkably
unchanged as the foundations of their
civilization are ecologically
sustainable and not inclined to
technological shifts in the ancient
Daydreamer prophecy which told of three
different Essences of a deity Creator
water land and air finding each other
again has now been largely relegated to
a myth in all their travels sea stewards
have never encountered flying life forms
with advanced intelligence so many
assume the third Essence never existed
after all
yet there are regions the sea stewards
have yet to chart few species from the
shallow sea Venture past the
southernmost Islands but this young
glacial Fox Trotter the last of the
three-legged canither lineage is about
to stumble upon a forgotten land
crossing a newly formed Bridge of sea
ice the fox Trotter reaches the southern
continent of sarinostra this Frozen
region is a wasteland yet it is not
uninhabited a few creatures eke out
their lives in Serena's least welcoming
environment like the Fearsome snow
scrounger these scavengers are the
Single Living descendant of the squirk a
tentacle bird lineage that hasn't been
as successful as the trunkos in adapting
to the changing world the snow
scrounger's presence makes life on
sarinostra an uneasy Prospect for the
lone foxtrotter Against All Odds though
it will establish a place here and will
not be the last Fox Trotter to do so
yet Saran Austra isn't the only Frozen
Wasteland on Serena its northern
counterpart the continent of saranarcta
is home to a long-lost relative of the
ocean-going gravedigger The Savage
gravediggers are hulking predators that
lost the spark of sapience in favor of
physical strength rumors of these
monsters formed the basis of campfire
stories among the ocean-going
gravediggers although few believe the
story is to be true
and there is another remarkable species
on sarinarcta that has slipped the
detection of the sea stewards the
blue-tailed chatter Ravens are a
Territorial and often aggressive
omnivore species that are nonetheless
abnormally intelligent for the chatter
Ravens or the descendants of the white
margin chatterers a species notable for
being the pet of the last woodcrafter in
the chatteris r in turn distantly
evolved from the Babbling Jays the first
Advanced intelligent life to emerge on
Serena for a brief time all those eons
ago in the present chatter Ravens are
intelligent enough to possess a
rudimentary language but none of them
are truly Sapient that is except for one
bright eye is a young chatter Raven with
a rare mutation that allows for abstract
thinking and Imagination he is a genetic
throwback having regained the spark of
his ancestral species and he isn't the
only mutant in his family his brother
whose name translates to White Crown was
born an outcast due to his lack of
pigment unwelcome within the brutal
chatter Raven hierarchy the two siblings
set off on their own across Saran arcta
while isolated in this harsh Wilderness
they at least have each other and bright
eye has seen things he can't explain to
his younger brother visions of species
he doesn't recognize and Whispers from a
mysterious voice telling him he's not
alone and although neither knows it yet
the actions of bright eye and white
crown will change Serena for millions of
years to come
many dangers await the brothers in the
snowy Wilds of Saran arcta on silent
fur-lined Wings the startling snow
Spirit stalks prey like a vengeful ghost
the Ice Age descendant of the early
ultimason tribats snow Spirits
fortunately rarely go for prey larger
than rats like born owls they are
nocturnal hunters and have convergently
evolved a facial disc to improve their
hearing in the winter Darkness spotting
a snow spirit's large expressive eyes is
a frightening sight
yet there are larger Predators than snow
Spirits scissor Jaws the last species of
the once thriving sir quagga dogs or
Hunters with asymmetrical Jaws capable
of bringing down large Predators the
scissor Jaws though are on the absolute
brink of Extinction for they are being
systematically hunted by a force they
cannot hope to understand
while journeying across the ice the
brothers encounter the body of a fallen
scissor jaw while White Crown takes the
free meal without question bright eye
can't help but wonder what kind of a
predator hunts without eating their prey
soon the brothers find the answer a
woolly giant roams not far from the
Fallen scissor jaw bright eye recognizes
it as a plant eater and more remarkably
notices what appears to be a tool in its
trunk-like beak and when their eyes meet
bright eye recognizes something else the
spark of intelligence this is a Woolly
wumpo the largest living land animal of
this age and one of the most intelligent
at long last sapiens has struck within
the tentacle bird lineage The Woolly
wimpos possess a unique language and can
use tools but they are fearful of
outside dangers eliminating the scissor
Jaws due to the Potential Threat they
posed
in wampos have good reason to be wary
not only are their numbers few but they
are sometimes hunted by none other than
the chatter Ravens on their own a flock
of chatter Ravens has no hope of taking
down a wampo but they have a grim
hunting strategy by singing in Eerie
Harmony they can alert large predators
to the location of Lone wumpos and then
feed on any scraps left behind
but bright eye isn't like most chatter
Ravens through silent gestures he is
able to convince the wumpo an elder
whose name roughly translates to blaze
that he means her no harm and what's
more bright eye is able to indicate his
intelligence from here on out their
lives are intertwined
convincing the other one pose that the
two chatter Ravens aren't a threat isn't
an easy task for Blaze as their society
has long been fearful of Outsiders but
Blaze knows that somehow these chatter
Ravens are special communication between
such separate lineages isn't easy as
bright eye can't register most of the
sounds that make up the wampo language
but like the gravediggers and the
woodcrafters long before them they find
a way through the use of symbolic
drawings bright eye and Blaze break down
the communication barrier inventing a
unique language of pictograms soon other
wumpos learn to do the same in a new
world of possibilities opens up between
them
at the same time the sea stewards have
come to a grim realization that all
other species on Serena are blissfully
unaware of the planet is freezing over
and soon the ocean will be uninhabitable
but if there's anything the sea stewards
excel at its cooperation towards a
common goal and there are rumors that
the gravediggers of the northern coasts
have discovered something beneath the
ground that might help traveling to the
north the stewards discover vast
deposits of peat and coal formed from
the remains of ancient tropical swamps
these deposits also house the bones of
huge and terrifying animals that roamed
across Serena millions of years ago
transporting these materials to the
southern ice sheets requires an
engineering project of unmatched scale
but the stewards are determined to save
the sea
transporting thousands of tons of
material to the expanding glaciers and
setting them Ablaze the stewards begin
to experience some success but the
region their minds are located in is a
perilous one home to the monsters of
their myths demons that look like they
do but attack without Mercy their
project cannot be completed quickly
enough
yet unbeknownst to the miners they're
being watched bright eye is curious
about these new arrivals but Blaze sees
them as monsters for there is a legend
that all wumpos know that tells of an
evil that came from the sea
Generations prior to gravediggers made
landfall and began to hunt the wumpos
not recognizing their intelligence in
retaliation one wampo stole fire from
the gravediggers to drive them back but
couldn't control the wild substance and
caused the destruction of the herd and
themselves now all wampos fear the
gravediggers in the fire they command
but bright eye isn't convinced he
believes the fire could be an asset to
the wumpos and himself if only they
could learn to make it and as a
descendant of a speech mimicking bird
through careful practice he is able to
ask the gravediggers directly how they
make fire one can only imagine how the
first Gravedigger reacted to hearing a
talking bird a scene right out of their
oldest prophecy an unbeknownst to Bright
Eye his actions will ignite more than
just coal
word of a talking bird spreads like
wildfire among the sea stewards at last
the prophecy seems to be upon them the
third essence of their deity the wings
having seemingly arrived so when bright
eye asks the sea stewards to give fire
to the wampos and leave them in peace
who are they to say no the stewards
engineering project is nearly complete
and with the danger of ice on the
decline sharing fire seems like little
consequence and far away a presence
watches all this unfold some of what it
sees impresses The Observer yet other
things have it worried with the mass
extraction of coal a Pandora's Box was
now open for the first time in 270
million years of its observation
something has arisen within the project
that has the potential to destroy it
the wampos use the gift of fire to drive
back any predators that threatened the
herd White Crown eventually departs
Guided by instinct to return to the wild
in time Blaze departs too the Elder
wumpo passing away peacefully bright eye
Mourns his loss and becomes increasingly
frustrated with the strange expectations
of the sea stewards
then to his horror bright eye discovers
a growing Wildfire spreading across the
land the chatter Ravens following the
example of his brother whitecrown have
learned to use fire to hunt but they
can't control it the fire spreads to an
underground coal seam in an apocalyptic
chain reaction begins like the ancient
wumpo who thought they could control
fire bride eye now realizes the depths
of his mistake in perhaps the greatest
tragedy in all of Serena's history The
Inferno spreads for miles across the
land all the way to the Sunset and so
this chapter of the world ends not with
ice but with fire
from miles away the sea stewards can see
the fire too and know their world is
coming to an end and from far away the
Observer the one who has overseeing this
experiment since the beginning feels
something it isn't supposed to feel it
feels guilty by whispering to bright eye
that he was not alone all those years
ago it interfered and now everything had
fallen apart
dying on a smoldering Beach bright eye
hears the observer's voice again it
apologizes for all the suffering its
curiosity caused but bright eye doesn't
care and with his last breath he spits a
curse at his creator
on the southern ice shelf alone snow
scrounger notices the sky glows a
brilliant orange it has no way of
knowing a global apocalypse is consuming
Sarina but the Observer knows what is to
come just as it knows everything that
came before over the course of Serena's
history The Observer has witnessed many
tragedies seen many brilliant Sparks go
out and never has it interfered yet this
tragedy was the indirect result of its
own meddling and as the Observer
reflects on the last living moments of
one Brave Little Bird it makes a
decision it is never before made to
offer help
appearing to the surviving sea stewards
as an amalgamation of many Sapient
species The Observer speaks it tells
them their world is ending because of
the consequences of the choices it made
so now it is giving them a choice the
sea stewards can go to a planet just
like the one they know except where the
fire never happened and the ice will not
close in so that one far and distant day
their descendants will swim across a far
wider sea the sea stewards accept
the sea stewards awakened to a calm
night having forgotten all they have
seen to them nothing has changed and not
a moment has passed the Observer has
solved its conundrum splitting off the
sea stewards and cloning their familiar
world to colonize a new project as a
compromise for its interference on this
new world the sea stewards culture is
now free to advance
yet far away back on Serena the
experiment isn't over yet with the
Observer returning to its impartial
surveillance Serena is left to see
through another mass extinction on its
own with its major keystone species
effectively gone in an instant the
consequences will be severe as Serena
closes the door on one chapter and
enters its final age
six hours into the late Ultima scene the
dawn Rises on a world without the sea
stewards ravenous nemacorn Thorn grazers
feed on the bodies of animals claimed by
the fire which continue to burn through
the coal seams beneath the Earth in time
the sea shogoths no longer provided with
regular meals will revert to their
ancestral condition and so Serena enters
a wild era where for now only the
toughest living things will be rewarded
the mighty bloats are one of the first
species to vanish from this new world
with no natural defenses against Horrors
like the sea shagos they make for easy
Targets in just a few centuries only the
skeletons of these Mighty Oceanic Titans
remain as Cyrano warms and the ice melts
the oceans grow deeper in decaying plant
life adapted for the shallows turns the
Seas toxic resulting in almost 95
percent of ocean life becoming extinct
on land a great thaw has begun
duck-billed sea lumps the only sealum
species still capable of walking arrives
in large numbers on sarinostra fleeing
the collapsing Oceanic ecosystem the fox
Trotters that arrived here just five
centuries ago find food is more
plentiful as do the snow scroungers
in Saran arcta the ice has also
retreated allowing for a rise in
biodiversity yet the loss of the
glaciers brings forth its own dangers
millions of years of built up ice
exerted in extreme force upon Serena's
crust creating concentrated subsurface
Pockets with the pressure now relieved
the planes have been transformed into a
deadly Minefield over the coming eons
volcanoes will come to life after tens
of millions of years of dormancy which
will result in even more rapid warming
yet Serena eventually begins to heal
several Millennia later there are few
visible signs of the sea Steward
civilization left with the occasional
exception of a Gravedigger knife or a
Shard of pottery exposed through erosion
their legacy though has left one final
mark on Serena the awk vulture always an
intelligent species that learned to
perform tricks in exchange for food has
evolved to be even smarter now that they
must fend for themselves
most stock vultures are highly
intelligent for an animal but among a
small population which refer to
themselves as Reapers a fluke of Nature
has caused the spark of sapiens to arise
once more the reapers are a spiritual
Melancholy group who knows their kind is
not likely long for this world yet one
Reaper whom we will call Eve will play a
central role in a story unlike any other
The Story begins in the atmosphere above
Serena something that looks like a comet
from the surface is circling the moon
two pods detach and crash land on the
ground sustaining heavy damage these
mysterious probes are perhaps the First
new stimulus to enter the closed system
of Serena in over 270 million years
losing connection to the host satellite
they are now very much alone
one of these bizarre probes sets out
from the crash site searching for the
other from the sky the reaper known as
Eve watches the strange star creature
with curiosity she's never seen anything
like this being that moves like a living
thing yet doesn't seem to be alive
soon the autonomous probe finds their
sibling has not survived the crash they
will have to explore this strange New
World all on their own
but Eve follows the being which he names
felstar on a journey across the
Uncharted surface for she is alone as
well having not seen another intelligent
Reaper in over a decade
at first philstar spends their time
cataloging the world around them with
mechanical indifference but in time they
take notice of Eve who points out native
species to the Curious robot over time
felstar's personality grows bigger and
they learn to communicate with Eve
through gestures in imitation across the
widest chasms they Forge an unbreakable
Bond two lonely Souls isolated by space
and time ultimately find whatever they
need in each other they travel for many
seasons and find there is much to live
for eventually felstar no longer seems
to remember how or why they came here
the story never directly States what
kind of intelligent life made felstar
but given their avian appearance in
gentle nature it seems likely felstar is
an emissary from the sea stewards Planet
while the sea stewards no longer
remember Serena and having lost contact
with felstar may never find it again the
possibility that their civilization is
out there thriving somewhere in the
stars is a comfort after so much
devastation
yet eventually everything no matter how
extraordinary must come to an end one
might assume that felstar would last
beyond Eve or perhaps Beyond everything
but while felstar doesn't age or require
rest they're not immortal like most
machines felstar isn't built to function
forever and so they simply fall apart
piece by piece bit by bit over the years
like a skeleton upon the planes while
philstar doesn't mind Eve does using
scavenged parts to keep their dear
friend functioning long past their
natural lifespan while both of them know
felstar's end is near they make every
day the best they can exploring new
regions and cataloging new species when
no easy fixes remain in felstar can no
longer travel Eve brings specimens
directly to felstar instead small
Comforts to take their mind off the
inevitable Eve is prepared to take care
of felstar for ever but she knows they
don't want this philstar doesn't fear
the end of their Journey like organic
creatures do in the end felstar gestures
for Eve to sit beside them and they
spend one final moment together
when the spark fed his felstar finally
goes out all that is left is a cold
shell Eve knows that her friend is gone
she knows felstar's body will stay where
it lies Untouched by animals and plants
slowly falling apart into fragments but
never truly Vanishing it's not a sight
she can bear to see so not knowing what
else to do she moves on Reapers
typically Embrace solitude but Eve soon
finds that being alone is not the same
as being lonely in time she realizes
that felstar would want her to keep
exploring to see what else is out there
beyond the world they walk together so
she decides to keep the adventure alive
in memory of her friend and continue the
pursuit of discovery
setting out on her own Eve has been
forever changed through her time with
felstar and seeks to be a benevolent
force in an uncaring world she adopts an
orphan Fox Trotter whom she rears to
adulthood as if it were her own child
and in time she discovers other
intelligent Reapers like her and becomes
part of their flock and so felstar in
life and death is a catalyst for change
within Eve expanding her world view and
continuing an ancient chain of ideas
shared from one species to another even
after the sea stewards have long left
Serena
Eve's flock might very well be the last
group of Reapers Under the Sun but they
face their fate head-on for in the words
of the author everything has its
beginning and so too everything has its
end but until that time they will not
stop living they won't give up one never
knows how long their story might be but
the world is wide and life is full of
surprises
the story of Serena isn't over yet the
end Ultima scene an era home to some of
the most unique life forms of all is
just beginning but that's all I can give
away for now if you find this project as
incredible as I do I'd encourage you to
check out the main website Linked In the
description and read more of Dylan
beta's incredible project of Serena
and as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video